hello first of all thank to everyone who
came here today for our talk
if Gaudi had a cluster we feel honored
that the fantastic organizers of Strange
Loop
invited us to speak here today alongside
all these other great creative thinkers
in fact I'm kind of surprised there's
anyone in this room with this all the
stocks happening in the other ones I
would want to be there not here but like
that's me yeah thanks for coming and
last year but after we attended Strange
Loop
I couldn't stop talking about it for a
month it's a really special conference
and it's full of really amazing people
and I want to thank both the organizers
and everyone who is visiting this
conference it's great to talk to all of
you guys cool so we're here today to
talk architecture both software
architecture and building architecture
plus clusters and programming languages
and hopefully have a little fun in the
process so the premise of this talk is
what if Antony Gaudi the Spanish
architect whose work pretty much defines
the Barcelona cityscape what if he lived
a hundred years later than he did what
if he had access to you know the massive
amounts of computing power that we kind
of take for granted today so how would
his architectural practice which is you
know arguably some of the creative in
human history you know how would it have
changed
but first you might be wondering who
those people and why do they care so
much about architecture my name is max
Rick Gaurav I am distribute systems
engineer and I used to build a large
systems for Yahoo Google our B&B and
then I joined flux to build the tools
we're gonna be discussing to here today
yeah so my name is Jenny Carlisle and
I'm a co-founder and engineering lead at
flux and flux as a start-up in San
Francisco and we're building an open
platform for the architecture
engineering and construction industry so
you know we're a mixture of software
engineers and designers and architects
and structural engineers and more and we
think that technology and the smart use
of data can really dramatically improve
how we design and build buildings so as
part of the flux platform we've built a
graphical web-based programming language
aimed at architects and engineers and
you know with this
based programming language it basically
offloads the heavy computation from a
user's machine and up into the cloud
where we can you know spin up resources
on demand so later we're gonna talk
about our approach to designing and
building this programming language you
know and what we learn from it kind of
the good the bad and the ugly and
everything in between but first we're
going to talk about a little bit about
gaudi the man and then we're gonna cover
a brief history of modeling in
architecture then we have a few demos to
kind of spark your imagination around
the question like what if gaudi had a
cluster and then we're going to switch
gears and talk about the language we
developed the system architecture our
approach kind of frameworks we chose and
why and what we learned in the process
so this is Antoni gaudí he was born in
1852 in a family of copper thermos in a
small town just 70 miles outside
Barcelona he he spent much of his early
years in the families coppersmiths
workshop and as a coppersmith you
constantly have to think specially is
the surface of this bang consistent
throughout what is the volume of the
spot examining things like that helped
him develop great ability to think
specially and competitively other
architects who were mostly using
representative representations like
drawings his thinking was firmly rooted
in 3d space
yeah and for any of you who are curious
this is called an Alembic and this is
for distilling liquids and it's just one
example of you know something that gaudi
might have built in his family's
workshop right so go deal I arrived in
Barcelona when he was just 17 four years
later he became an architecture student
graduating after six years of studying
he plays himself and gained a strong
reputation in Barcelona architecture
scene in the early 80s he became an
assistant to an architect fantastic
DiPaola Villar who was commissioned to
build la Sagrada família well luck with
the project in eighty eighty three after
this agreement was a group commissioning
the church
and slowly but surely Gaudi took over
the project first you stay true to the
original plans but then he little by
little adding a little bit elements here
and here in there
he changed the project to be in his own
unique organic style yeah so Gaudi
worked on la Sagrada família for 43
years from 1883 until his death in 1926
so like just imagine that like you start
working on a project when you're 31 and
then for the next 43 years you devote
like your entire being to that project
you know every waking thought your
creativity your energy it's really
pretty remarkable towards the end of his
life Gaudi decided to decline all other
professional projects and he devoted
himself to creating plaster models and
sketches and drawings of Sagrada família
so that work could continue after his
death so he actually predicted that the
project would take about 200 years to
complete which I couldn't I think about
that my mind kind of explodes like we
train ourselves to think about like what
am I going to get done this week or this
month or this quarter you know imagining
a project that goes on for 200 years is
pretty mind-blowing just for fun here's
a picture of the Sagrada família
building site in Barcelona a complete
with goats I hear goats are the new cats
so this is probably like circa early
1900s so pretty different than the
Barcelona that we know today um but
before we move on I want to sprinkle in
a brief mathematical interlude and talk
to you about a fascinating thing called
catenary curves so catenary curves are
all around us kind of like the tip of a
power line between towers like a
necklace a spider's thread or
clothesline if I pick up this chain this
is actually I'm now holding a catenary
curve in my hand you know and being in
st. Louis we can't forget about the
Gateway Arch this is a really beautiful
example of an inverted catenary arch so
a catenary curve is you can think of it
as the average of pure exponential
growth and pure exponential decay and
can be
presented with this formula here when
the scalar a equals one you get this you
know nice very beautiful and a curve
here in black the cool thing about the
catenary curves can be demonstrated with
this chain when it hangs the links
settle in a position where all the
tension forces act alongside the line of
the this disart right when inverted the
forces of tension becomes the forces of
compression and those forces also act on
one side the line this is makes it the
perfect shape for a free-standing arch
because the forces are so strong
supporting it that you don't need any
outside support like bracing your
buttresses if you build a cantinori arch
out of the bricks the forces are so
great that you don't need any mortar to
hold it it's just gonna hold itself
under its own weight that's pretty cool
construction I think and we bring its up
because Gaudi use continuity carves all
over all over his projects specifically
in Sagrada família all the towers at
canary can't continue in shape before a
Gaudi catenary arches were used in like
bridges but no one try to use them in
normal architecture so and there is one
other interesting of kind of less common
use of catenary curves in the built
environment so if you actually build a
set of catenary humps you can ride a
square wheel bicycle over here this is a
mathematician his name's Stan waggon
this is the late 90s and so as long as
the side of the square is the same
length as the arc of the of the catenary
hump you can take this kind of
ridiculous device and you know propel
yourself down the road just pretty fun
so ona switch gears a little bit and
talk a bit about the use of models in
architecture both physical and digital
so when you think of building design you
probably think of you know like
blueprints and drawings and two other
two-dimensional representations but you
know many architects want something more
something more physical or spatial where
you don't have to use
your imagination as much to kind of get
a sense of what a building will look
like or feel like when it's complete so
and this is when they turn to models
physical models physical models have
been used for hundreds of years and for
you know all sorts of different reasons
and architectures so a model might be
used to explain a complicated design or
to you know show the interaction of two
volumes might be used to like get buy-in
from a client or just like explain a
complicated design idea so with models
and I'm sorry with architecture you know
you can think of it architecture is
really about creating spaces and when
you only have two deer Epperson tations
you really have to like use your
imagination to think of what that space
is going to feel like but if you use 3d
models it's a lot easier to get
everybody kind of on the same page and
imagining the same space right and the
past couple of decades the architecture
profession is turning more and more to
virtual models and of course they're
fast iterate easy to visualize and lower
overhead than physical ones
some brief people are even turning to
virtual reality to communicate their
designs
now we're gonna share some particularly
interesting models with you guys so this
first one this is Eero Saarinen and this
is a model of the TWA terminal at JFK
Airport so it was commissioned by
Transworld airlines in 1955 and then
opened its doors in 1962 and it's
actually part of JetBlue's JFK
operations so if we have any like New
Yorkers in the audience you might have
actually been to this terminal so um the
exterior of the building is this
concrete roof that's meant to like
emulate a gigantic bird in flight and
the inside is really beautiful
you have this kind of continuous ribbon
where the the ceiling kind of flows into
the walls and those walls flow into the
floors and Saarinen use models to answer
all sorts of questions he mostly built
his models out of things like cardboard
and wire and a little bit of wood but he
used them to answer questions like how
should the roof be shaped or how are
people going to circulate within this
space or just like what's it gonna feel
like inside
through this picture and just for fun
he's like really diving into his model
love it I justify it fun side note if we
have any like furniture geeks in the
audience you might know Saarinen for his
mid-century modern furniture design so
he's known he's the creator of kind of
the ubiquitous tulip table and tulip
chairs and one of my favorites here the
Blum chair it's like great for hours of
napping rate and typically physical
models are made of things like cardboard
plaster wood wire but sometimes more
ephemeral more transient materials are
used so this is an example of Frei Otto
a German architect he was active after
the Second World War and during that
time there was a lack of construction
materials around Europe and he used
properties of so bubble to generate the
enclosures with the maximum volume and
minimum surface space so he he would
actually use the properties of bubble
itself to kind of compute I guess the
shape of the building yeah
and shiftings is somebody more
contemporary I'm guessing most of you
have heard of Frank Gehry maybe raise
your hand if you've heard of him he's
pretty famous like starchitect yeah so
he has a really interesting practice
that marries the physical and the
digital so he actually iterates his
designs using physical models like this
one and then when he's satisfied he uses
this device called a Faro arm which is
basically a portable measurement arms
whoo
with this you can basically
reverse-engineer a physical model and
create a digital representation from it
so once he's you know they've created a
digital representation other focus in
the building trade will work off that so
like structural engineers and mechanical
engineers and he has a pretty unusual
practice like max mentioned before most
people start with digital because it's
like a lot easier to make changes and a
lot faster to iterate but you know we're
not going to tell Frank Gehry how to do
his job and of course we cannot forget
about Gaudi
his modeling process from more
a hundred years ago is still pretty
awe-inspiring and amazing of course he
used the wood and the wire and the
plaster and all of those materials but
the most famous of his models is
actually the chain model of la Sagrada
família he would take the links of chain
hand him from the ceiling and then add a
little bags filled with like teeny LED
weights in them which would control the
shape of those Canton Airy curves that
we know off that that's really
mind-boggling right I mean just think
about this process you're like hanging
chain after chain from the ceiling you
want to change it a little bit you have
to like remove a few links from the
chain or you take a few weights out of a
bag that you've tied there it's just
like very painstaking and time-consuming
and you know this this model here is
actually what kind of inspired us and
led us to the question like so what if
gaudi had a cluster so for fun a few of
us at flux built an app on the flux
platform to explore this question so the
first question we asked was like what if
gaudi could build a parameterised model
of sagrada família and explore you know
a hundred or a thousand design
iterations in the time it would take him
to do one using his manual processes so
we're gonna start a video here so what
you're gonna see is a parameterised
model of sagrada família so you can see
what we're starting with and we can
change things like the number of bell
towers change it from three to four and
then in just a couple of seconds we get
our new model we can change the
dimensions of the floor plate we can
kind of stretch it out a little bit and
then would go in another couple seconds
we can do things like change the height
of the main tower zoom out to see the
results and then you know our old friend
the catenary we can change the a scalar
parameter to change the shape of the
curve no this is a lot easier than like
changing you know taking chain links out
you can also do things like change the
height so like you know every single one
of those iterations is like a couple of
seconds and
you know you can just imagine how much
time that would have taken him back when
he was building his physical models so
another area that piqued our
imaginations is biomimicry so biomimicry
is when we imitate nature to solve kind
of complex human problems so Gaudi was a
deep lover of nature particularly
naturally occurring geometric forms and
you know if you look at his buildings
they just like scream organic at you and
if you look closely you can see how he
applied kind of naturally occurring
motifs to his design so one example is
on some of the columns in the external
facade the base of them are what's
called it's kind of a mouthful I
sometimes mess it up called hyperbolic
paraboloids and it's actually the same
shape that you find at the base of this
is a cap octree here so also just kind
of fun fact if you take the webbing
between your thumb and your forefinger
this is also a hyperbolic paraboloid so
I think this quote kind of sums up his
attitude pretty well you know Gaudi was
a deeply religious man and he found
nature to be very spiritual so besides
studying trees he studied things like
crystals and like falling seed pods and
cereal grains like wheat and native
grasses when he was designing Sagrada
família so we wanted to add this into
our demo as well so in this application
okay so in in this video we're looking
at the ornamentation on the tops of the
bell towers and we start with a crystal
form but you can very easily change out
to a different motif so now its stalks
of wheat at the top and then you can
change it and now it's Nautilus shells
as ornamentation and now we can change
it in to a tuft of grass and besides
changing motifs we can actually change
the parameter so we can make it less
compact so it kind of bows out or we can
make it much larger you know or we can
make it more dense so kind of add more
blades of grass I think now I can kind
of look at the results and pretty fun
and then finally we asked ourselves you
know with his deep interest in kind of
organic form and nature would Gaudi have
been fascinated with the idea of genetic
algorithms so what if you let you know a
thousand generations of Sagrada família
is kind of grow and mutate and swap DNA
like what if you let them evolve so we
built that in this interface you can
launch a genetic algorithm and it
launches a thousand generations each
generation has 50 candidates in it so
we're generating 50,000 different
churches basically and then we run each
each model through a fitness function
and then whatever model has the highest
score of that fitness function we deem
it the winner
so you can check out what we're starting
with and then we can launch the
algorithm and it's all running in the
browser and we get our our best
candidate out of the 50,000 we can load
it and check it out what it looks like
it doesn't look too different let's run
it again this time we've got one with
just four bell towers load it see how it
looks yeah so we had a lot of fun
building these demos I hope they kind of
spark your imagination around the
question you know what if Gaudi had a
cluster yeah so imagine Gaudi now has
his cluster and now he has to tell it
what to do so he needs a programming
language but what kind of language would
do you want ask oh of course
maybe go all right let's be serious here
for a second
we are not gonna tell you we'll give you
a huge lecture and how to design a
programming language that a lot of
people are doing that Harry a lot of
people can do that here and we don't
even have enough facial hair amongst two
of us to to do that what we can do
instead is pander to our imaginary
client mr. gowdy yeah so first of all
Gaudi was a very you know visual thinker
so we think he'd prefer visual tools
over something text-based you know
architectures full of sketches and
models you know formulas and text too
but you know we think that something
visual is preferable to something
symbolic second we think that the
language and environment must have you
know means for easy reuse like the same
way a software engineer doesn't want to
like write basic data structures and
sorting algorithms every time she like
writes code Gaudi doesn't want to start
from scratch every time he begins a new
project and you know if you had a good
over idea over here you might want to
reuse it over here or if he was inspired
by the work of you know some of his
contemporaries maybe he'd want to take
that idea kind of remix it and then use
it in one of his projects so you know we
think the language would need to have
some elements of reusable components
and of course there is performance
imagine the smooth running of High
Definition high frame rate video and
watching it you'll be taking out of your
chair into the middle of the action you
would get into that famous state of flow
and then imagine the video start
stirring the framerate drops you'd be
yanked out of the state right away right
so architects when they're working they
really want to stay in that flow state
all the time
right mr. gowdy does not want to take a
break and go for a walk whenever he
changes a parameter on his model now
that walks are not great they're really
good for you should all take them but
anyway they're architects and mr. Gurley
specifically want their moles to be
really responsive CPUs are amazingly
fast these days and GPUs are enormously
powerful right but it turns out that
even by today's standards the
architectural problems are still pretty
hefty as an example a normal skyscraper
project might have 10,000 or even more
facade panels just just for the facade
right like a facade and then each one of
them is an individual entity that you
have model or you model independently
right so has the language has to be in
handli parallelizable what we mean by
that is that the user who's using the
language does not have to think about
concurrency and all that stuff well he's
making his program work right mr. Gogi
is not a distributed systems programmer
and he doesn't want to thank and spend
his weekend thinking about the business
he'll fault tolerance or version of
civilization protocols and another thing
not really a programming language
specific but more of a development
environment requirement architects to
repeat ourselves are very visual people
and they want an output of the program
not also not to be a text but to be some
graphics some some kind of geometry
hopefully in 3d and not just the output
of a program but also the debug output
your
winters if you will should be that so it
should be really really just like it's
easy to print something out of your
script it should be as easy in our
environment to generate the output in 3d
yeah so you know what fits the bill
what's a language paradigm that's visual
component eyes bowl reusable
parallelizable you know we thought long
and hard about this when we started
designing this language and we actually
came to the conclusion that flow based
programming is actually a pretty good
choice so flow based programming for
those of you who are not familiar with
it in flow based programming an
application is designed as a or it's
represented as a directed graph so each
node in the graph is a unit of
computation you can think of it as like
a little black box it's actually a
little black box here and then the edges
in the graph represent data flowing
between those units of logic a block can
be really simple it can be a primitive
that just you know adds two numbers or
it can be something complex like a
complete graphics kernel here's one
example of a really simple flow that
takes two numbers and sums them and then
takes a third number and multiplies the
result of the sum by that to get nine in
this example and then here's a more
complex example where we take a solid
volume and then we just slice it at
regular intervals another thing that's
kind of cool about SLO based programming
is it's really easy to kind of inspect
your application logic and kind of get a
big picture view of what's going on so
people tend to cluster related logic
together so there's like a cluster here
in red a cluster here in green you know
in a cluster here in blue so you can get
an easy sense of what's going on and
then also something that's really
important is parallelization is
basically inherent with this model so
you can think of each block as a remote
process and then you can think of each
edge as an RPC call and so this
obviously isn't like the standard way to
program computers but it actually has a
pretty long history and a pretty loyal
following so people started
experimenting with flow based
programming in the mid 60s
and architecture particularly generative
building design is kind of part of that
loyal following if you go into an
architecture firm it's much more typical
to find people who are proficient with
graphical programming than like writing
scripts like Python or C sharp or
anything like that now we're going to
talk a little bit about our approach to
designing flux yeah so when we started
out we identified kind of four
principles that guided our development
so the first principle was we wanted the
language to be visually clean so there's
nothing in the way just the necessary
blocks and connections all the blocks
have the same kind of equal visual
weight and we found that this kind of
reduces noise and mental overhead and
allows you to kind of understand what's
going on more easily also you notice
there's no like proliferation of buttons
and toolbars in architectural software
like AutoCAD and Revit this is a really
bad problem like you get these toolbars
that it's like button bonanza they have
like 60 buttons on them and it's just
not the nicest rate and second of all we
wanted the environment to be modern and
seamlessly collaborative there may be
hundreds of people collaborating on a
large buildings at nowadays and believe
me or not but the current state of art
is faxing each other flat drives so we
decided to improve on that a little bit
the other point is we wanted to spare
our users hours of arguing with the IT
guys so instead we run the entire front
end in a browser without any
installation needed and the back end is
running on our clusters of powerful
servers our third principle was this
idea of smart abstractions so we didn't
want to build a language that was too
low-level
you know smart abstractions kind of
allow users to get started solving their
problems very quickly and easily so with
flux we built a standard library that
people can use and it you know has
operations related to you know
mathematical operations and flow
control and graphics and you know it's a
very carefully curated set that we you
know were curating for kind of
completeness and orthogonality and it's
extensible when this standard library
doesn't cut it
users can implement new blocks or modify
old blocks using JavaScript and so once
we had our guiding principles we started
actually building the language in the
authoring environment so this is a
picture of the authoring environment our
flow based authoring environment if you
kind of squint it looks like a cross
between a spreadsheet and an infinite
canvas the horizontal rows are called
streams and they're meant to help a user
could have organized their logic at a
macro level so in graphical programming
like the rat's nest is a really common
problem I can imagine this is your
program nobody talked about spaghetti
code yeah like literally looks like
spaghetti like I'm hungry looking at it
so that's why we introduced this idea of
streams to help people organize their
their logic and so just a quick example
if you had a project you could have a
stream that was had one stream about
structural design and one about building
your building facade and one about
energy analysis so you know a lot nicer
than that big old rat's nest that we
just saw okay so now we're going to talk
a little bit about the technology or the
architecture that is behind this so I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
front end and then I'll turn it over to
max and he's going to talk about the
back end so yeah as you can see this is
a pretty complicated front end and so
when we started building it back in 2014
we evaluated angular and react and
polymer and ultimately ended up going
with polymer which is Google's web
component polyfill library we were
really drawn to the idea of web
components because you know they're
modular and reusable and composable and
the idea of shadow DOM like really
piqued my interest like the fact that
you can have encapsulated CSS and
JavaScript and HTML and it doesn't leak
all over your document was really
intriguing
you know in retrospect one takeaway I
have is I wish we would have looked or
thought a little bit more carefully
about one of polymers mantras the mantra
is everything is in element and like
mean everything so even our non visual
components like data models or the
element that we use to track you know
user actions and you know get metrics
from it these are all elements and so
this led to just like massive Dom bloat
for small flows this wasn't a problem
but for anything kind of substantial we
would have liked over 20,000 30,000 Dom
nodes and it just led to pretty bad
performance problems so as an example
just this one component this one block
that takes into numbers and adds them
just had on the order of like 40 Dom
nodes and a flow like this that's fairly
complicated this would take like an
embarrassingly long time to load like
over a minute and this when we realized
on blow it was such a performance
problem we it caused us to kind of back
off on our use of polymer and move
towards just like more vanilla
JavaScript so the main thing we did was
take everything that was non visual and
then we converted them into pure
JavaScript components and then we did
this kind of ugly but this hack where we
have to require Jas to work with HTML
imports and these are like apples and
oranges so it wasn't pretty but it did
work thankfully and it helped with some
of our performance problems my other big
takeaway was you know sometimes it's not
a bad idea to like choose boring
technology like I love this article by
Dan McKinley if you guys haven't read it
like I highly recommend it
you know my natural tendency is to like
use the bleeding edge thing or like the
most shiny thing and that often is not a
good idea if you're trying to ship a
product so I'm gonna turn it over to max
now and he's going to talk about this
great so the big kind of flux is a
distributed system written and go with
C++ you can think of it kind of like a
compiler and a distributed virtual
machine at the same time the most
important components are the flow is a
queuing engine over here
big blue one then the value store and
decide the coast or under it and the
block worker pull over here so what
happens when the program comes into the
system is its analyzed by the flow exec
you should engine
it basically compiles it and of like you
know internal representation then it
figures out which blocks have stale
State and schedules they concrete block
execution on the concrete block workers
out of the pool the pool is kind of
large we run it and a bunch of servers
and there is a block worker like work
worker pool on each server and those are
pretty simple servers themselves they're
written in go and internally they
contain the v8 the JavaScript virtual
engine virtual machine built by Google
for the Chrome browser and later open
sourced so the blocks are on the block
workers again and they read the inputs
from the value store and they write the
outputs to the value store to the code
store contains the vinter program code
and the individual block code an
interesting abstraction we implemented
while working on this is something we
call the remote pointers
those are act kind of like the C++ or C
pointers you know and like but was a
twist that the values themselves can be
on a remote machine not even memory but
also on disk
whenever you dereference the pointer
like that it might invoke a network
fetch operation the reason we did this
was to our scale flow solution engine to
we larger programs and to we larger
number of programs than it can run
concurrently the entire system is very
concurrent and the benefit of it was
always that also that we could get some
of the performance back because some of
the outputs of the blocks can be very
large and being smart about where we
keep them instead of fetching them all
over the system brought a lot of
improvement
we also had our fair share of learnings
while being the system one of them the
big one was that when you're building in
tightly connected distributed system
utilization and RPC overheads does to
matter a lot so we got a lot of benefit
from switching from Jason over HTTP to a
more modern and more performant stack of
serialization and RPC libraries right so
you might be wondering like why did we
build all of this well to bring guca
texture models into minecraft obviously
but thrilled though there is actually a
very like real-world scale problem here
you know the urban population is growing
cities are becoming more dense the land
in cities is becoming more scarce and
more expensive you know I was reading
this article from the UN Population
division and it was saying that the it
predicted that the urban population is
going to grow by an additional 3.3
billion people by 2050 which is roughly
double what our current urban population
is today not the world population but
the urban population so if you do the
math on this if we want to how is 3.3
billion people we can compute how many
buildings we need to build so if we
assume that we can house 250 people per
building it means that in the next 34
years we need to build 13.2 million
buildings which is like that's a lot of
buildings and if you take it one step
further we can compute how many
buildings we need to build each day
every day for the next thirty four years
and we get this kind of mind-blowing
number of 1063 so every day we need to
be building a thousand buildings and our
current building process processes and
practices are just too slow and too you
know resource intensive for us to keep
up right and it is staggering scale like
that
think about the improvements that even
the minor optimization in you
materials can bring like how much mortar
or brakes can you save with that right
or even after a building has been built
a minor adjustment in a direction it
faces can result in the sense of a
percent of like energy savings for that
building imagine that doing it happening
at a scale right now those optimizations
are only possible for the largest
projects we want to scale them to
everyone so I mean these are like
massive problems it's kind of a lot of
gloom and doom but you know at our core
like we are optimists and we think that
even though these problems are hard they
can be solved you know computers and
technology is already helping people you
know helping humanity do things like
your cancer and mine asteroids and so we
think it's time for you know building
design to kind of lend itself to the
optimizations that are there to be had
and then you know beyond that we
basically want to empower the modern
gaudi's kind of the architects of today
to kind of explore the deepest reaches
of their imagination so that's it thank
you so much for coming to our talk I
think we have a few minutes for
questions
thank you
[Applause]
in the back yeah yeah so this one this
is just
I'd call it a prototype right now so we
built part of our platform we have an
SDK so I built we built this using our
SDK and built the genetic algorithm kind
of on top of that but actually genetic
algorithms they seem to really capture
the imagination of the architecture
industry and of all sorts of kind of
generative algorithms you know genetic
algorithms seem to be like one of the
favorites so I expect us to build it in
at some point oh yeah Fitness function
is pretty pretty it's all based on the
golden ratio so it's a pretty simple
fitness function it takes the floor
plate wings so like the the X and the y
and it tries to optimize for the golden
ratio and then it takes the height of
the bell towers and the main tower and
tries to get to the golden ratio if I
were to extend it and make it better I
would also add in kind of a kind of
material cost so if like you know it's
if you want to build super tall towers
it's going to affect the fitness
function in a negative way as opposed to
shorter towers and actually we consulted
an engineer who works with low birth on
projects like that before and golden
ratio was the first thing that came out
of his mouth that's actually how
architects do this
um you know to be honest we built this
during a hackathon no we have not
thought about it but yeah overall
absolutely if you can formalize an
actual function like you know if it's
like smooth over over the surface of the
optimization whatnot you can absolutely
do analytic optimization on it or like
numerical optimization back in the
purple
so the question was the question was
whether director graphed some particular
shapes and we find patterns and how
people build those programs yeah not too
much I mean the thing that you tend to
see is people really do like cluster
their logic that have to do with a
certain topic so you just you'll see
clusters but like the shape of those
clusters haven't seen a ton of
commonality between them I feel like
it's a very user dependent like think
about coders when they write their code
they have their own idiosyncrasies about
how they structure the code same here
people have an idea how it should look
like and they follow that idea usually
I couldn't catch it so your question is
could we provide like a set of tools to
help people like organize them
oh no I hadn't thought about that that's
a cool idea yeah
yes question is whether we do have a
Minecraft interface fine enough yes it
was built doing the same hackathon I
don't think it's published yet but there
is an engineer who's really read excited
about it and he doesn't want to let it
go it's being it's kind of a cool
thought you could like take a real
building model that you have in like
AutoCAD or Revit or one of these like
real design tools and like boom got it
in Minecraft yeah do you know yeah
anyway I was thinking of the Legoland
yeah any other questions
all right last minute
the question is whether we have an
ability to produce other models outside
of a new texture so I guess what yeah
it's kind of a complicated question and
so part of our platform we have a set of
basically you can think of fluxes like
this central hub and then we have a
bunch of plugins for other pieces of
software that translate your model
that's expressed in flux - you know
however a model needs to be expressed in
say like AutoCAD or grasshopper so these
are all built we have two SDKs and all
of our plugins are built with that and
they're open-source so somebody if they
wanted to take a model that was in flux
and then express it in some other
program they could build their own
basically build their own translator I'm
not sure that right we're taught to
finish up here so we'll just hang around
outside if you guys have any hair anyone
has any other questions thank you again
for coming thanks for the questions
[Applause]